well for many years I've been very I
think aware of things going on in the
community and interested in in the
community so I've always lived here
pretty much all my life and I just felt
that it was probably time coming towards
the end of my career to start giving
something back
I represent lower Brent it's a large
rural ward very sparsely populated apart
from one or two centers and also it has
some very active and thriving
communities they do so many things and
people really work together to do as
much as they carefully
it as leader of course I'm there to
represent that the district and also
effectively to be the the first port of
call when people have grievances they
often come to me straight away with and
because I'm the public face of of bay
but in terms of what I enjoy most I
think really it's I I do enjoy
interacting with my fellow members that
there are some challenges but it's good
to be able to talk to them and work with
them on solutions that affect the whole
history
every month I go to parish council
meetings I give a report and I listen to
what's going on and I build up a
relationship with with the parish
councillors and that that I find that
the most rewarding aspect it's it's the
the ward representation and being the
liaison between the ward and the
district
a very room mystery is renowned so many
things
Constable's Gainsborough and and many
other artists it's also has a huge
amount of tourism offering and and in
that respect it is a window onto East
Anglia for the rest of the country and
further afield people come from all over
to the various things that we have to
offer here in Baber not not just
obviously the the areas and that's
that's only natural beauty and things
like the wool towns but also of course
since the war with the connection with
the Americans through the American Air
Force and the airfields here we have so
many visitors from from America
well that's a good question I do enjoy
gardening and it's relaxing I enjoy
walking and up until fairly recently I
used to do a lot of horse raipur being
laid out right I had to give that up
because as I said this is a pretty much
a full-time job